comment ne pas se souvenir de mes neil
cette candidate de l'émission the voice
qui s'était retrouvé en plein coeur
d'une importante polémique pour avoir
porté un voile dans l'émission de tf1
si de nombreux téléspectateurs s'étaient
indignés d'un tel signe extérieur
religieux dans une émission grand public
certains internautes étaient même allés
jusqu'à déterrer d'anciens message de la
chanteuse sur son compte facebook dans
lesquels des années plus tôt elle
relayait des théories du complot
notamment autour du 11 septembre
victime de nombreuses insultes racistes
sur les réseaux sociaux et se retrouvant
au coeur d'une tornade médiatique la
jeune femme n'avait pas eu d'autre choix
que de prendre du recul avec la scène et
de tenter de se faire discrète une telle
pression qu'ils avaient même décidé à
quitter la france pour s'installer dans
le colorado nouvelle vie nouveaux
départs je viens de me marier et j'ai
déménagé à denver dans le colorado
ce n'est pas simple de tout changer pays
amis maison activités mais le changement
me permettra de découvrir un peu plus ce
dont je suis capable
le changement fait peur au début mais
vous rend ensuite fiers de vous un
changement de pays mais pas seulement
sur les dernières photos de son compte
instagram
on peut s'apercevoir que mesnel à
quitter son voile et porte désormais un
simple ruban autour de la tête
un changement majeur pour celle qui
avait fait le choix de porter ce voile
lors de ses prestations et apparitions
publiques mais neil qui a décidé de
continuer la chanson et qui serait en
préparation de son prochain album
alors quoi qu'elle fasse c'est vrai que
ça aussi ça ccsa ces réseaux sociaux
parfois assez vrai que ça peut être très
très difficile vous pensez qu'elle doit
elle doit se retirer des réseaux c'est
pas elle de se retirer tant pis s'il ya
des gens qui veulent parler qu'il parle
quand on n'est pas content quand elle en
a pas on ne sait pas la critique à
l'époque c'était que c'était bien sûr
pas changé le débat n'ont plus rien mais
là elle revient sans voile oui tout le
monde mais s'il a dit à l'époque je suis
à quelle échelle jamais excusé par 100
voix alors que sa mère très joli